qui est dans la panade il s'appelle
Pierre Palmade
vous avez votre avis là-dessus et il
fait partie de votre collègues quelque
part mon avis et qu'on en parle trop on
en parle trop alors aujourd'hui tout le
monde lui tombe dessus en disant tout le
monde était au courant c'est vrai que il
y en a d'autres même au plus haut degré
de l'État qui se farine le pif donc oui
oui alors donc bon c'est pas nouveau je
trouve ça lamentable moi je le fais pas
mais bon si vous me dites sur les
politiques là vous rendez compte oui oui
alors voilà voilà alors
Gilles
alors Gilles oui non non mais c'est vrai
alors c'est un lanceur d'alerte
[Rires]
soyons honnêtes quel lanceur d'alerte
ça fait 20 ans que tout le monde dit que
dans que dans le secteur de la drogue
qui circule etc là au moins il a envie
de le dire il le dit très bien
en revanche et en revanche quand il dit
jusqu'au plus haut sommet de l'État moi
ça me choque en revanche
moi je découvre effaré un truc qui a
l'air normal et qui circule sur le
réseau depuis la sortie de de cette
affaire avec la carrière
avec la carrière que tu as eu est-ce que
tu as déjà vu quelqu'un se droguer à
côté de toi et ça alors ça vraiment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non moi je suis je trouve
qu'effectivement avec un Palmade il y a
quand même un beau bal de focus
concernant l'utilisation de la drogue
dans notre métier dans notre métier je
parle de chemise alors si la question
est-ce que ça m'est arrivé je vais vous
répondre franchement oui c'est bien
d'avoir testé cette saloperie si c'était
votre question est-ce que la question
mais je vous le dire fais des soirées de
ouf toi non des fois non pas j'ai fait
des soirées j'ai fait des soirées j'ai
fait des soirées Palmade il y a très
longtemps voilà Félix et j'ai vu un
stand de gens dont je t'ai rien non et
même quand j'avais 15 ans que je sortais
dans une nouvelle qui s'appelle l'Élysée
Matignon qui était une grande boîte que
vous avez connu des gens extrêmement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans cette boîte de nuit j'ai vu des
gens extrêmement connus voilà consommer
des produits stupéfiants il y a une
boîte dont tu as parlé Raymond où
j'étais quand j'étais jeune quand on est
25 ans que c'était le Banana Café
c'était la fête du slip c'est quoi le
café
c'était un bar très sympa qui était tenu
par là non moi j'en ai pas mangé
personnellement mais mais
il y avait de la drogue en bois bien sûr
bien sûr mais il y a des tas de boîte
dans Paris Cyril où vous allez dans vous
vous allez dans les vous allez dans les
dans les toilettes c'est le défilé c'est
pas c'est un secret de polichinelle moi
ce qui m'a dérangé un peu avec Palmas
qui n'enlève rien à l'horreur de la
faire c'est que j'ai vu parler des gens
qui honnêtement ils se foutent ils se
foutent de la gueule du monde parce que
ça a été les premiers à faire la fête et
ce qui est en soi voilà c'est interdit
par l'homme il y a plein de gens qui
font la fête moi j'ai eu la chance de de
pas tomber dedans mais j'aurais pu
tomber dedans c'est voilà un moment
il y a une période de ma vie où si
j'avais pas été comme comme il faut
l'être entouré avec des enfants une
femme de l'amour on peut faire des
conneries moi j'ai eu j'ai eu cette
chance là et moi j'ai enfin des enfants
des femmes de la femme non mais voilà
très sérieusement Cyril c'est vrai que
c'est c'est un piège dans lequel on peut
tomber très facilement dedans et et
c'est c'est une connerie comment tu es
tombé dedans toi j'ai envie de savoir
moi j'étais tombé moi je ne suis pas
tomber mais arrête comment tu prends
pour la première fois comment tu prends
ça comment tu penses arriver parce que
tu es alors moi la toute première fois
de Mamie que j'ai été ça c'était à Los
Angeles c'était c'est très à la mode
là-bas il y a un mec qui vous dit tiens
et c'est ça et puis voilà comme
un con tu essayes comme un con j'essaie
voilà bon après voilà j'ai essayé j'ai
j'ai j'ai passé une tête voilà ça m'a ça
m'a pas plu plus plus que ça et j'aurais
pu j'aurais de la chance il y a des tas
de gens il y a plein de gens qui ont
essayé on va pas se mentir qu'est-ce que
tu peux dire aux gens qui nous regardent
c'est c'est qu'est-ce que c'est de la
merde ah non mais Cyril c'est c'est de
la merde et je veux dire quoi c'est les
mains parce que effectivement c'est de
la merde parce que au début ça vous
semble extraordinaire c'est pour ça que
c'est de la merde le piège c'est qu'on
vous a laissé cette saloperie et comme
ça c'est pas voilà c'est pas ouf et que
ça vous rend un peu mieux on tombe
dedans il ne faut pas essayer il faut
pas tomber dedans moi j'ai eu la chance
de m'en sortir encore une fois parce que
j'étais pas dans un état de dépendance
etc et j'étais pas dans des soirées
délirantes c'était plutôt à la maison
avec mes copains mais c'est vrai que je
suis un je suis un peu étonné que la la
la la bien-pensance là aujourd'hui donne
des leçons et parle alors que c'est vrai
que dans ce métier voilà c'est quand
même monnaie courante et
si si tu en as vu ici non jamais
de la vie attendez moi je parle de ça
c'était c'est c'était il y a 10 ans mais
c'est une chose c'est vrai c'est une
chose qui a beaucoup circuler peut-être
un peu maintenant c'est peut-être moins
moins tendance et je pense je voulais
sincèrement que la faire Palmade va en
calmer un certain nombre qui vont faire
bien plus attention qu'avant mais je
trouve qu'effectivement commencer à
crier au loup quand on a traîné comme
j'ai pu traîné dans des soirées dans des
boîtes où vous voir des gens chez moi et
cetera c'est vrai que certains se
foutent un peu la gueule du monde quand
même il manque pas
vous allez réagir dans un instant je
fragile d'abord non mais il est quand
même on passe le cacher il y a une
protection au niveau de la cocaïne voilà
c'était su et tu alors après on peut se
dire c'était nous aussi on aurait pu
dénoncer à ce moment-là il y a eu une
sorte de
voilà on a on a mis ça sous un couvercle
et tous on aurait dû moi le premier moi
j'ai pas pris de cocaïne mais j'ai pris
autre chose je vous l'avais dit
désenferamine à un moment on aurait dû
essayer de la merde il faut le dire
en fait ton cerveau oui c'est vrai vous
avez exemple il faut vraiment pas en
prendre non tant mieux qu'une prise de
conscience sur le fait que prendre de la
drogue c'est pas cool parce que pendant
des années moi je repense à cette
interview qu'on a vu de Pierre Palmade
chez Laurent Ruquier ou en fait pendant
15 minutes le mec disait au calme qui
prenait de la drogue que c'était cool et
limite les gens applaudissaient parce
que c'était un artiste parce que c'était
un écorché vif non la drogue c'est pas
le Cool c'est de la merde ça tue ceux
qui en prennent et ça tue le le ceux qui
en croise le chemin donc c'est bien qui
cette prise de conscience à cause ou
grâce à l'affaire Palmade c'est plutôt
bien que ça change rien
et c'est vrai que c'est un piège
redoutable parce que quand on quand on
en prend notamment des amphétamines mais
ça ressemble aussi à la drogue de
synthèse 3 et même c'est dont on parle
dans l'affaire Palmade le problème
problème Cyril après il faut le dire à
tous les jeunes c'est que on se sent
tellement fort tellement puissant on se
sent médiocre et on ne peut plus s'en
passer donc c'est un piège mortel faut
surtout jamais en prendre et c'est vrai
que il y a une tolérance des vues il y a
une tolérance à propos de ses drogues et
dans les boîtes de nuit parisiennes dans
les clubs à un moment voilà et aussi
dans les milieux du people il y avait un
snobisme de la drogue voilà il faut
rejeter tout ça je crois qu'il y en a
moins aujourd'hui globalement quand même
est-ce qu'elle veut
participer à l'émission
[Rires]
dans tous les milieux sociaux que ce
soit la télé que ce soit les banquiers
que ce soit des traders que ce soit
n'importe qui
[Musique]
il y a des personnes qui en prennent et
ben psychologiquement elles vont se
retrouver entre elles que ce soit dans
n'importe quel milieu donc en fait là
moi je suis pas d'accord avec la phrase
les politiques les stars bah non en fait
il y a des il y a 1000 autres milieux où
ils prennent de la les gens prennent de
la drogue si ils ont les moyens ils en
prennent malheureusement et c'est ça qui
est triste parce que moi ça fait
maintenant six ans que je suis dans la
télé et j'ai jamais croisé la drogue de
ma vie le seul jour on m'a proposé de la
cocaïne c'était en boîte de nuit donc je
vois pas le rapport avec les stars et la
télé c'est un espèce de mythe mais en
fait il y en a dans tous les milieux
sociaux malheureusement alors justement
un charcutier trader
c'est en fait c'est pas que dans les
stars après il y a des métiers où moi
par exemple dans dans les métiers de la
livraison j'ai jamais vu des livreurs
arrivés le matin et prendre des rails de
coq avant de prendre le camion
c'est c'est une dépendance aussi mais la
drogue c'est chez les stars moi j'ai
plus entendu que chez les stars à
l'époque de Jean-Luc Delarue et
compagnie que il y avait beaucoup de
drogues dans le milieu du show must et
tout et depuis je suis là bah c'est
comme Kelly j'en ai pas vu moi ici j'en
vois pas ni partout ni dans les loges
ici j'ai pas vu de mecs drogués
alors tu parles de Jean-Luc Delarue bien
sûr il y avait la fin qui sont voilà qui
sont bien sûr exprimés sur sur Game
Ardisson notamment et cetera Mathieu toi
qui est dans le métier depuis longtemps
moi franchement j'en avais plus vu en
finance pareil
quand j'étais à l'époque année financier
en finance il y avait beaucoup d'argent
et tout ça mais la télé je suis arrivé à
la TNT et la TNT il y avait pas de
thunes donc je suis arrivé NRJ12 j'ai
toujours connu la télé pas je pense que
c'était la télé d'avant les les cinq
chaînes où il y avait plein d'argent
plein de festivals de Cannes et tout ça
moi je suis arrivé NRJ 12 il y avait pas
d'argent ont été mal payés on vendait
mal nos émissions donc j'ai toujours
connu la télévision entre guillemets TNT
et dans la TNT pardon mais NRJ12 je vous
le dis je n'ai jamais vu de drogue on va
rien dire c'est pas une question
malheureusement bah je dis pas n'importe
quoi je te dis que je n'ai pas vu de
drogue à NRJ12 dans la mode oui dans la
mode et mannequin des années 90 début
des années 2000 elle prenait la cocaïne
comme à manger en fait pour pas manger
pour être tout le temps en forme pour
maigrir c'était catastrophique des
laxatifs et juridiques et de la coke
voilà et c'était fourni par des bookers
par des agents un peu dégueulasses et
j'ai vu des drames qui se faire des
complètement dans la drogue
non mais on a dit non mais
tranquille
elle va chercher des noisettes
[Rires]
on a tous connu des animateurs des
producteurs des gens dans la production
qui prennent de la drogue bien sûr que
si arrêtez en télé il y en a de la il y
en a de la drogue il y en a eu on aura
toujours et ça fait c'est vrai que ça
fait partie ça faisait partie d'un
lifestyle d'un mode de vie un peu cool
pour dire je travaille dans le showbiz
je prends de la cam tout le monde
connaît ici quelqu'un qui a déjà pris de
la drogue mais pour autant quoi en faire
en fait on va dire que c'est de la merde
et que c'est pas cool justement on va
pas dénoncer les gens tu vois à l'époque
de la rue par exemple les collaborateurs
de la rue le savait le savait pas on
sait pas mais pour autant ils l'ont pas
outer c'est lui qui l'a dit lui-même
c'est un des pionniers de ça un des
premiers qui avait beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup de notoriété et qui alimentait
ce fantasme que quand on a un artiste
quand on est une vedette quand on est
une star c'est cool de prendre de la
drogue et ça ça alimente le talent et
que c'est bien non c'est de la merde ça
sert à rien au contraire ça détruit les
gens et ça détruit des carrières mais
arrêtez de dire que vous n'avez jamais
vu personne prendre de la drogue dans ce
métier dans ce milieu
de la table ne connaissent pas quelqu'un
dans le milieu tu peux tu peux entendre
des choses mais on peut en sort pas avec
on n'a pas de lifestyle dont tu parles
ah non non pas vous moi je connais aucun
animateur avec ton chat qui leur aurait
fallu dénoncer ou euh etc mais quand on
te dit ah tu sais machin et bah il prend
ou machin il tape ou machin mais si il a
jamais fait si tu les fais si toi tu
n'es jamais sortir avec lui
[Rires]
tout le monde le savait comment on le
savait agile non mais à un moment
Géraldine on le sait très bien avec
Benjamin il y avait des endroits à Paris
des clubs peut donner le nom d'un parce
qu'il existe plus donc on peut y aller
par exemple le Doobies qui était un club
privé il y avait il y avait mais les
banques que j'ai connu à un moment on
savait très bien et ben tu ferais mieux
d'en prendre
2 secondes
on savait très bien qu'on allait au bain
si on pouvait entrer il y avait des
acteurs ou des actrices américaines ou
des mannequins qui arrivaient la cocaïne
leur était livrée et on voyait ça de
mettre de nous donc c'est c'est non mais
il y avait des jantes télé qui était là
aussi donc il y a eu un système de
protection à un moment dont on est tous
responsables sans doute mais qui a
existé ça c'est vrai on peut pas le nier